[Music]
you know often on the daily cancellation
i'm going out on a limb on my own to
cancel somebody bravely canceling what
nobody has canceled before but today is
a somewhat rare occasion where i will
join
a pre-existing cancel mob to cancel
uh someone by the name of james charles
james charles is a famous youtuber known
for
uh wearing makeup a while ago he became
a cover girl
even though he's not a girl and
this fact that he's not a girl is
something that he apparently needs to be
reminded of
charles is as the media tells me facing
backlash
for a youtube stunt where he experienced
pregnancy for a day
experienced pregnancy for a day and by
experienced pregnancy i mean that he
wore a prosthetic belly
and took some nude pregnancy photos and
that's it
that was the essentially the extent of
his pregnancy experience
because i know you really want to see it
here it is
watch all of our close friends are all
in a group chat together and a few days
ago we were all joking around with her
and she came back at us and said i bet
you could not last
24 hours of being pregnant and i thought
to myself okay
challenge accepted so for today's
youtube video laura is going to join us
and we're going to be doing a ton of
different challenges and tasks to really
see if i
am strong enough to experience what it's
actually like being pregnant for 24
hours straight let's get started
you're squishing the baby
oh a little sideways tactic i was insane
you definitely want your knees
okay i'm a professional dog clearly
since i got
[Music]
yeah very healthy but more subtle yeah
like that
now like james charles i am not a girl
so like james charles i don't know what
pregnancy
is like but i'm pretty sure after having
watched my wife go through it several
times that it
involves more than having to sit
sideways at the table so your stomach
doesn't
get in the way there are all kinds of
psychological emotional hormonal aspects
to the experience that cannot be
replicated also bladder related aspects
i'm told so if you really want to give
pregnancy simulation a shot
you should at least once pee yourself
from
sitting down too fast or however it
works
the backlash charles is experiencing
comes from people claiming that he's
minimizing pregnancy and making a joke
out of it
i agree that he's doing that um and but
i think the cancelling should go further
because this is not
just minimizing making a joke out of
this is appropriation
and it is appropriation far more
degrading and reductive
than say a white person wearing a native
american headdress for halloween
so he should receive a consequence at
least as harsh as
the one we would dole out for the person
on halloween wearing that costume
the rules should be applied consistently
i am a firm believer that the left
should be required to live by its own
standards
even if i don't agree with the standards
these are your standards
you should have to live by them in fact
i'm the one who shouldn't have to
you you should have to not me
so that's why when it comes to the left
standards i will
i will passionately defend any
conservative against the left's
standards but i will take those
standards
and passionately argue that people on
the left should have to live by them and
that doesn't make it a double standard
for me
no because again they're not our
standards they're yours
you live by them i don't care what you
think about appropriation or anything
else
but you should care what you think
you're the one who thinks it
now um in this case though
it really is appropriation okay and it's
part of a larger cultural trend wherein
men are claiming womanhood for
themselves turning womanhood into a
costume they can wear
claiming female spaces for their own uh
taking what rightfully belongs to women
in fact
the only kind of identity that is
actually being appropriated in this
culture is womanhood
it's not possible actually to
appropriate a culture that doesn't exist
cultures are fluid cultures are ever
changing culture is a human construction
culture is always influenced and always
always influencing others that's the
nature of culture it cannot be
taken it can't be stolen somebody
participating in your culture is not at
all
infringing on your ability to experience
your own culture for yourself
in its fullness cultural appropriation
doesn't exist
yet it's the appropriation that we hear
the most about female appropriation
does exist yet we hear almost nothing
about it
despite what we're told sex is not fluid
it is not a construct it is not a
societal invention
unlike culture what's more a man
participating in womanhood
is depriving women of their ability to
experience it in its fullness
for example a man who participates in
female sports is effectively taking
female sports away
from females and on a deeper level girls
are raised in the belief that their
identity their femininity their girlhood
is mutable
changeable superficial i ask the famous
question all the time what is a woman
well we live in a culture that cannot
answer that question therefore girls are
brought up in this culture
deprived of an identity that has meaning
deprived of
a definable identity that's
the consequence of female appropriation
it's serious it's real
everything the left says about cultural
appropriation applies here
it doesn't apply there but it applies
here
james charles is a womanhood
appropriator of long standing
this is by far not his first foray into
cheapening womanhood degrading it
using it like a toy and for that he's
canceled
he should be canceled just as much as
any cultural appropriator ever has been
and more much more
instead he'll get some mean internet
comments and then continue along with
his life unimpeded
corporate sponsors still intact
corporate sponsors by the way
that should be going to women real women
not a guy who pretends to be for clicks
and clout
so james charles is officially
cancelled by me anyway
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content